مساء الخير من يقف وراء مذبحه الكبيره
التي جرت في سيريلانكا اليوم الاحد الماضي
واحد وعشرين ابريل 2019 الحقيقه السؤال ده
يقتضي منا نحنا نفهم سيريلانكا اولا وفهم
مسيره ليس صعب على اي مواطن بيعيش في
منطقتنا لان سيريلانكا بتشبهنا من وجود
كثيره بتشبهنا من حيث الاحتقان الطائفي
ومن حيث الخضوع للنفوس الاجنبي اه للدول
الكبرى ومن حيث النخب الحاكمه اللي بتقدم
مصالحها على مصالح شعوبنا لما كانت حسن ان
ت تقرع لبنان العراق سوريا احيانا مصر اه
ربما اقول المدخل السهله والمباشر اللي
حنا لفهم سيريلانكا نحنا نعرف ان اساس
سيريلانكا وهي جمهوريه عباره عن جزيره
موجوده في المحيط الهندي جنوبا
يفصلها عن الهند
في اضيق مسافه في ال الماضيه حوالي اربعين
كيلومتر يعني يفصلها عن الهند جنوب لين
حوالي اربعين كيلومتر فقط لا غير تاريخيا
سريلانكا كانت منطقه واقعه تحت النفوذ
الهندي لكن مع صعود النفوذ الصيني والقوه
الصينيين اللي حب تنشر نفوذها يعني
السياسي والاقتصادي والعسكري على دول
الجوار بدا الاهتمام الكبير للصين في
سيريلانكا بالنسبه بالنسبه للصين واحد من
المحاور المهمه في مشروعها الضخم جدا اللي
هو مشروع طرق الحريري وهي بتعتبر سيره حكم
موقعها المميز نقطه مهمه لربط اه اه
بضائعها او يعني
مراكز الانتاج في الصين الى مراكز ال اه
المراكز اللي تستقبل بضائعها في كل ما
كانت في العالم علشان
السيريلانكي تتهمها فهي قرارات انها
تستثمر فيها بمليارات الدولارات دون
الاقتصادي الشهير بيقول ان الدول وتخضع
الدول بطريقه من اثنين يا اما بالسيف اما
بالديون والصين قررت انها تخضع سريلانكا
والدول الاخرى مثل ها بالديون هي ب تستثمر
استثمارات ضخمه سيريلانكا غير قادره على
السداد كل هذه الديون في مقابل عدم سداد
الديون الصين ب تضع يدها على هذه الاصول
الاستثمارات استثمارات عباره عن موانع
عباره عن مترات طرق من صناعيه الهند
غير مستعده لا تقبل بهذا الوضع مش قادره
تتقبل انه الصين اللي بتمثل لها خص ومنهم
يعني تاريخ من التوتر والعداء لعشرات
السنوات يصل نفذها على بعد اربعين كيلومتر
في منطقه هي كانت منطقه نفوذ تقليديه
وبالتالي هي مصر هي تبادر ايضا بخطوات
مشابهه يعني هجوم مضاد اللي هي تضغط على
الحكومه ال في سريلانكا بانها تقبل
مشروعات انديه بنفس الحاجه بحيث يكون بكل
مشروع اه صيني في مشروع عندي يعني كل مطار
صيني في ميناء هندي بكل طريق صيني في مصنع
عندي وهكذا لانه اكثر ما تخشاه الهند مش
بس التمدد ال ال النفوس الاقتصادي ولكن ان
تتحول سيرين كل قاعده عسكريه متقدمه على
بعد اربعين كيلو منها والغرب هذا القلق
اليابان قلق ايضا صراع الدولتين على سير
تنفيذه يحتاج الى ادوات واهم هذه الادوات
هي السياسيين اللي هو دين على الارض بان
الصراع طبعا كل دوله من دول عندها ركلات
هاو احزابها وادواتها بين الصراع ده وصل
الى ضروره في اكتوبر السنه اللي فاتت 2018
لما رئيس الدوله الحالي اللي هو سياسيه
المحسوبه على الصين قرر التخلص من رئيس
وزرائه الكرمي رئيس وزرائه محسوبه على
النفوذ الهندي وبينهم خلافات كثيره يعرف
السياسات رغم انهم كانوا حلفاء في 2015
الصراع الاساسي او الخلاف الاساسي هي
الدفاع عن المصالح الهندي في المقابل
الدفاع لصالح السيد لكن بعد فراغ ستمر في
السلطه لعده اسابيع
نجح يعني او حكمت المحكمه الدستوريه
العليا لصالح رئيس الوزراء الحالي وبقي في
منصبه النتيجه نحنا عندنا
راس السلطه التنفيذيه في سابك رئيس الدوله
ورئيس الوزراء احدهم محسوبه على المعسكر
الصيني والاخر محسوبه على المعسكر الهندي
والصراع مكتوم
ويبدو الحسم قانونيا لكنه مستمر في
التصريحات اليوميه ومنها التصريحات
الاخيره لرئيس الوزراء اللي ب يلمح فيها
مسؤوليه او تقصير رئيس الدوله فيما جرى من
مذبحها على اراضي سيرين الخلاف السياسي
بين الاطراف المختلفه دي والصراع الاقليمي
على سريلانكا بيجري على ارضيه جدا
اللي هي اثنين وعشرين مليون سبعين في
المائه منهم هي من اه يعني عباره عن اه
اغلبيه من عرق السوس اهليه وزنها لديه عرض
لكن بينها الاساسي هو البوذيه
اطناشر في المائه من اهالي
من المؤمن التاميل وبالتالي العراق لكن
غالبيته او دين الهندوس والجزء المتبقي
حوالي عشره في المائه من المسلمين
8 فى الميه مسيحيين
التركيبه دي على بعضها دائما كان فيه
احتقان طائفي وعرقي جدا لو حبينا بشكل
مخليه نسبيا يعني هو نقدر نقول ان السنه
حاليين اللي هما البوذيين بمعنى اصح السنه
الكوريه هي بتشوف انه السنغاليين ليس ولا
يمثل الاغلبيه الا في دوله واحده في كل
دول العالم
وهي دوله سريلانكا وبالتالي بيعتبروا انه
سيرين كان السنغاليين البوذيين واليوم
شعار بيرفعوا بيقول لك ان تكون سلوكيا
يعني ان تكون بوتين والحقيقه انه عندهم
تنمويه وخوف وعدم الثقه في باقي الاقليات
او في اي دوله تتعامل القصه دي لها اسباب
ولها تاريخ مكشوف الفراغ الجزيره مختله
منذ مئات السنوات
البرتغاليين وبعدين الاميين ثم
البريطانيين اللي حصلت لينك منهم على
استقلالها سنه ثمانيه واربعين لكن التاريخ
الطويل وتفاصيل كثيره النتيجه احنا شديده
جدا الضغط التي اسفرت عن صراعات ومذابح
كثيره بدايه من 1915 والتاريخ بس كلنا
مذبحه ورمز مثلا من بين ما بين ال ال
الطرف الاساسي دائما اللي موجود اللي هو
السوريين او البوديين ثم الاقليات
المختلفه
صدامات ضد المسلمين مره مره ضد المسيحيين
ما شوف ليش احنا صدمات ما بين الاقليات
بينها وبين بعض بشكل المنكر
كانت ظلت في الاحد لسنوات طويله من سنه
ثلاثه وثمانين 2009 بسبب الحرب الاهليه ما
بين البوسنيين
واقليه التاميل راح ضحيتها يعني عشرات
الالاف في تقديرات للامم المتحده تقول
انهم حوالي مائتين الفراغ
الحرب الزائد ما انتهت بسلام لكن انتهت
بهزيمه للتاهيل
النتيجه انهم يسلموا لرغبه الاغلبيه من
البوذيين لكن ما زالت الضغائن موجوده دي
مش ما بين التنميه وما بين الكوريين فقط
ولكن ما بين البوديين ايضا وبين المسلمين
والمسيحيين عم بيتهموا الاقليات ين دول
بيقولوا هم عندهم امتدادات خارجيه و بيتهم
وهم في محاوله يعني بس هو المسيحيين بانهم
محسوبين على قوى غربيه و مدعومين من الغرب
و بيتهموا المسلمين ان هم بيحاولوا سيطروا
على البلد معدلات المواليد المرتفعه وبين
عندهم جماعات متطرفه عاوزه تنشر الاسلام
علشان البوذيين يعتنقون وعندهم اتهامات
مشابهه للمسيحيين التي كان احنا قدام
مجتمع عنده احتقان طائفي وعرقي بشكل كثير
كبير الامريكان شوف مذبحه البارح طبعا
يعني من الفين وتسعه سريلانكا مع نهايه
الحرب الاهليه ضد التامين شهدت هدوء نسبي
مع قوى غير بعض الاعتداءات القليله اللي
كان احدثها في
مارس من السنه اللي فاتت وكانت اعتداءات
من ال
المدنيين على المساجد والبيوت المسلمه
هناك من ظروفهم تشبه الى حد ما
اللي موجودين في يناير اقول لحضراتكم انه
ال الاطار ده يعني شهدت هدوء الغايه يوم
الحد اللي فات اللي هو واحد وعشرين ابريل
دي كانت يعني اكبر حدث من سنوات طويله جدا
الاتهامات الاولى
للحكومه او
التحقيقات الاوليه بتتهم جماعه متطرفه
مسلمه هي قالت اسمها جماعه التوحيد
الوطنيه لكن حتى يعني ال اللحظه انه
المذبحه اللي حصلت من الحوادث القليله
اللي الحكومه لا تشير فيها الى داعش او
غيرها من الجماعات المتطرفه بشكل تلقائي
لا انه يصير عندها تاريخ عمليات ارهابيه
كثيره وعنف غير منسوب للجماعات المسلمه
المتطرفه وحتى لما التحقيقات الاوليه
اسفرت عن انها جماعه اسلاميه متطرفه
اعقبها في البيانات الاولى بانهما بيبحثوا
الان هل وراء هذه الجماعه ال امتدادات
الدوليه يعني في دوله تعمها لانهم مش
قادرين يقتنعوا انه ماذا تستفيد اقليه
مضطهده من الحكومه على اقليه اخرى مضطهده
اذا كان التطرف واذا كان رفض الاخر هو
السبب كان الا بضرب هذه الجماعه انهى
تعتدي على الاغلبيه
المسلمين وتشهد المسيحيين لكن هذا لم يحدث
ثم انه صحيح ان الغالبيه اللي سقطت كانت
من المسيحيين الكاثوليك
لكن ايضا ال ال التفجيرات طالت فنادق
فاخره يسكنها النخبه خلاف اه اه عمليات
اخرى او متفجرات اخرى كانت موجوده في طريق
رئيسي المؤدي الى المطار هو ال الاشتباه
في انه ما جرى هو اقرب الى عمليه تمت في
نطاق او في اطار صراع المصالح الضخم بين
النخب السياسيه وتم توظيف في البعد
الطائفي قد يكون طبعا يعني ممكن ان يكون
هذه الجماعه تحت يعني
تحت
بدافع من التطرف المنتشر في جنوب اسيا
وشرقا ربما يكون الدافع الاساسي هو بس
البعد الطائفي
لكن احتمال ضعيف في كل الاحوال علينا ان
ننتظر ونرى ماذا يجري في سيريلانكا التي
تشبه الى حد كبير
ونسال الله السلامه للجميع والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]